today we're talking about nintendo's new
most disliked video as well as leaked
details for call of duty 2022
my name is davonte and you're watching
gamespot news
nintendo's trailer for its nintendo
switch online plus expansion pack hasn't
gone over too well with fans with the
video now holding the record for the
most disliked ever on the company's
youtube channel if you didn't know the
expansion pack trailer reveals the tiers
and prices necessary to play n64 and
sega games and it has almost 120
000 dislikes at the time of this
recording and a mere
7 000 likes with a total count of 1.15
million views
so why is this well fans have criticized
nintendo's pricing for the individual
and family membership packages of the
expansion pack tier which costs 50 and
80 respectively for a 12 month
subscription the emulated games on offer
lack several features audio delay is
commonplace and there have been reports
of graphical lag during online sessions
the last time nintendo uploaded a video
that was so negatively received was in
2015 with its e3 trailer from metroid
federation force which received over 97
000 thumbs down from 1.5 million views
but alright this year's call of duty
isn't even out yet but rumors for next
year's call of duty have continued to
take shape new information suggests the
campaign will take inspiration from
movies like traffic no country for old
men and sicario and is described as
quote gritty and unrelenting the game
could have a morality system like red
dead redemption 2 and the campaign will
apparently feature a new level of gore
for the series as reported previously
2022's game is reported to be a sequel
of 2019's modern warfare from infinity
ward focusing on colombian drug cartels
another report from vgc said that
warzone will get a new map inspired by
2022's modern warfare 2 and it will
reportedly feature various classic
points of interest the site says quote
locales from the original modern warfare
2 will be expanded on and stitched
together creating a massive new map this
is likely to include a significantly
expanded version of favela and other
classic arenas such as afghan quarry
terminal and trailer park the rumored
new map coming to warzone for modern
warfare 2's release in 2022 may also
include a new mode that blends pvp and
pve in a similar way to battlefield
2042's hazard zone
that's enough shooter news for now let's
move on to something more family
friendly over the weekend one of the
most popular games on earth roblox
suffered an outage that lasted multiple
days fortunately for fans the game is
back up and running once again in a
recent blog post roblox corp founder and
ceo david bozuki said the server issues
were caused by a quote subtle bug in the
game's back end as for why it took so
long for things to get running again
well david said that came down to the
quote difficulty in diagnosing the
actual bug looking ahead david said that
roblox corp will release a more in-depth
postmortem report about what happened
once the teams complete their analysis
the message will also include details on
what the studio is doing to make sure
this type of outage doesn't happen again
additionally it sounds like roblox corp
will offer a payment of some kind to
creators to make up for losses related
to the outage so were you your kids or
your siblings just completely lost
without roblox this weekend let me know
in the comments and now let's move on to
another one of earth's most popular
games fortnite following a period of
testing for the past two years it's been
announced that fortnite will not be
released in an official capacity in
china on twitter analyst daniel ahmad
said the game was never approved by the
chinese government and he believes the
cost of any changes it might need to
make the game appease regulators and
cover associated licensing payments are
not worth it battle royale games are
reportedly strictly regulated in china
and games must make significant changes
to be approved for example pubg for pc
has not been approved for release in
china the chinese version of pubg mobile
is called game for peace and it does not
have any blood
but okay hit the comment section let me
know what you think of all of those call
of duty rumors
i'm just excited that the 2019 modern
warfare is finally getting its sequel
all the rest of the stuff you know take
it or leave it you know more more
realistic gore i don't know if i need
that but let me know if that's something
you really want in the game and i'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you